Jason Mitchell is here here you go you
know I'm from either from the shy or
from Straight Outta Compton or super fly
or everything [ __ ] go Island Skull
Island yeah the only fan in here of
Skull Island and I loved them yes owner
came in here when he found out you were
coming in like Skull Island was [ __ ]
yeah though it was probably the the most
like it was the most beautiful
experience I ever had my life weirdest
moment we filmed in Hawaii Australia and
Vietnam oh it's just the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen like Vietnam that
country itself alone is oh my god it's
so beautiful you know my dad's
generation doesn't remember it as being
as the reason he can't sleep what are
you doing Vietnam when you're not
shooting what do you go out and do um
you know here's the thing about being
black it was it was it was nice we
wouldn't like a lot of different tours
and things like that but you know the
language barrier was such a thing that I
was I was always like you know being
home before dark sounds like it was a
beautiful country man it was just a real
sight I think it was just a cheat to the
eyes you don't have been like you know
you don't see stuff like any women I'm
sorry any women oh come on the rabo
where'd you grow up New Orleans so did
you travel a lot growing up or anything
like that actually I'm an army brat
right so um
I was actually born in Germany and I
moved to New Orleans when I was like
three years old and then we left when I
was in the second grade and with to
Belgium for a while
and then we came back to New Orleans so
I was like I got the best of both work
was that kind of like whiplash at all
going from like New Orleans to Belgium
till like you're going to a place with
all this like culture and then you go to
Belgium which is just super white well
then snap right back to New Orleans
let's see the thing about
like military people like they had this
sort of what they call gods schools
right and it's just a cultural cluster
you don't have even sent a huge gumbo
pot of everybody yeah and um it never
seemed like super white you know don't
you know it was like my first girlfriend
was Filipino even though maybe because
it was pretty cool sharing a gentleman
[ __ ] Robert it was just I think you
taught me how to become a chameleon in a
people person because you're leaving so
you're so likely to leave and likely to
get attached to people you know it's
interesting I don't know I think um I
think I try harder for people to attach
themselves to me actually you know what
I mean I know that sounds crazy but you
know you kind of want that yeah
friendship feeling people who you don't
at me so you just like hey here's Who I
am and I'd like to know who you are you
know just put everything on the table
you used to be in the new guy see that's
what your personality pride develops
because you always have to win people
over exam years exactly like just when I
walk try to do I work I'm sorry sake
yeah I've seen you on like I've seen you
do multiple interviews where you start
the interview going like this was my
dream to do this show I know making
friends with the room quick yeah you're
on the talk and you're like my whole
careers led to this is low-key like
Rosie Perez is my like oh yeah my
celebrity crush some ice white men can't
jump was a formative movie in my years
dr. fearless but we also when you met
Rosie yeah when I met Rosie she was um
she was a lot calmer than I I don't you
think she's gonna come at you with like
that like she would be like have a lot
more like like energy oh god I mean but
she's a very like reserved so you know I
mean she's very uh like Timmy I just
didn't expect that oh she's longer now -
you forget that like you know
mellow out and it's like I loved it when
she was like 28 now you look at her
she's probably 50 and she's got kids and
it's just they're not the same energy
they had just calm down she still looks
good though yeah she's great
look at her yeah she's great yeah it's
like Marisa Tomei Yeah right the Gina
Gershon yes still yes Hey
still going I want to be a stepdad Rosie
when did you start 53 she looks [ __ ]
great yeah went from like just saying
they can't call me by my first name
so what did you decide that acting was
what you wanted to do Oh after I got the
first check serious stuff I just I never
saw anybody who would be coming back to
the only person who I know was like
Wendell Pearson you know but they still
I feel like they've both ventured on the
the city to become actors I mean it was
just like it was so taboo to me you know
I mean they had a workshop coming
through it was like you can be really
good at this I'm like all right whatever
you know just kind of just definitely
sort of knob yeah I did it just it
became something I was like kind of good
at this you know I mean and then after I
booked my first job I was like yo I was
on I was on set maybe like 12 hours I
worked for probably 45 minutes yeah my
check was crazy what was the first one
that you auditioned for and got oh Texas
killing fields it's like it was kind of
a penis filled with a Jeffrey Dean
Morgan Sam Worthington
yeah yeah it's kind of cool but it paid
well yeah you get around actors for the
first time and you've had and you've
never had like a real acting job and
they're like we're gonna be here for 16
hours you go this isn't a [ __ ] job do
you like I get to go take a nap right
now all right if I try to take a nap any
of my old jobs like you fired well I got
caught napping one of my old jobs in
like you're fired the [ __ ] Hatter
nine-one-one
taking a nap under my desk and you also
realize that when you're on a set people
are nice to you so it's like you're like
I'm gonna grab some coffee
we'll get it and then after a while
you'll [ __ ] I don't have to get anything
for myself and you feel as B for coming
from the world of comedy where you just
treat like garbage on the road we're
like sit in the green room I'm sorry can
I have a water look maybe yeah they're
like do you want something specific if
it's okay we can find something that's
not wheat I understand that you're in a
comedy club you want water they point
the toilet did you go through any of
that in the beginning of being like I
feel like I should be doing something
right now oh I definitely did yes I did
this film called dragon eyes right and
it was my first important role but I
still had hadn't got the concept of like
I can have whatever I were like well
actually it was her first time coming on
set and she brought like a bottle for us
to celebrate right I think you think
they gonna let us drink some wine the
house let's just try to like duck it out
so she kids there don't have no clutch
screw yeah I'm like really my uy you
could get a twist out good evening so
she's like well look let's see maybe if
we could find a corkscrew so at the time
uh 18 knocks on the door and they're
like you know let us know if you need
anything and I was like I think my mom
needs a corkscrew there's like of course
we just wanted of course really you
should be like mama you know you
should've been like mom you'll watch a
theater major sweat real quick how like
confidence in it cuz I feel like in the
beginning I'd be sitting there looking
at the people working on the set going
like why aren't
why aren't you guys just doing them
acting stuff this is why you know well I
mean to be honest I'm still the guy that
like
acts as if my mom was there or acts as
if I would have to you know
like deal with the repercussions of
doing some [ __ ] [ __ ] you know being a
decent person right like like for
instance like a lot of first team is
which is the the actual actors are that
are gonna be in the seed a lot of thing
we're like you know what I don't I don't
know how to make a bread with me I don't
want these people ride with me and I'm
like really you're gonna sit in the
front seat of a 15-passenger headed be
you know I mean that's weird and I'm
still that guy this that forces them to
get in the van yeah I mean I'm like no
like I'm gonna help move chairs I'm
gonna help move video village because
I'm gonna do it anything I'm a grown man
you know I'm in the middle don't like to
sit there like the stupid I want to be
like the guy who's honest enough to go
I'm not riding with them but I'm like
you and I'm like all right with them but
I don't want to ride with the chair gym
goes right now like the ongoing joke is
like that Jason it's hard to work
because I just I don't know I just don't
believe it over physically overworking
women I don't believe it physically just
standing there watching people do things
but you could help me yeah that's the
time go back faster you getting that
show had to be amazing for you I mean
good I mean you could I would assume you
can look at that show like I would watch
the whole first season it was kind of
obvious within a couple episodes like
this is gonna last more than one season
yeah it's a good show and your your part
on it is such an important meaty you
know part with so many like it's a
layered yeah hardened yeah it is so
crazy because when I first met later we
actually like held hands in agreeance
and prayed it was like one day we're
gonna work together you know what I mean
and a year and a half later she wrote
the show I started the show so it's like
it already has this sort of this this
this godly thing around it you know I
mean it just keeps getting better and
better and better and everybody is like
really kickin ass on the show are you
guys filming season 2 now we start July
ok yeah are you is there any part of you
that's like at least in the beginning we
have to represent Chicago like that's a
real story going on in real life that
people are the beginning the middle but
you don't that mean because I mean you
could do wrong by Chicago but did ya
just can't go back yeah
piss off and then walk back this had a
real identity you know a lot of a lot of
places are just people put them on the
map once they get on TV but it's not
like that of Chicago they you don't have
been there very deep red city people
like it from Chicago have you people
culture they like it a lot they like it
a lot but it was it was rough at first
you know what I mean because Bobby not
being from Chicago yeah
it was important for people to know it I
was gonna put my best foot forward
yeah yeah if you never visit the hood
they gonna be like how you know what the
hood like in Chicago so these things I
had to do you know like for Easter I was
like in in a you know in a backyard in
Chicago
yeah Chicago eating barbeque licking my
fingers with everybody else like an
insect okay what happens when you show
up to a barbecue in Chicago I would
imagine that everybody becomes aware
that you're there yeah absolutely
absolutely you know it goes from a very
small barbecue to like a Raiders out
there kissing babies kind of stuff oh
that's amazing that's amazing and it's
also funny to think just some you know
some like a white dude from North
Chicago's watching the shine and he's
like easy for over 40 years I swear to
god that's easy it's gonna be hot as
[ __ ] foam in there in July in August
how does [ __ ] ain't the word oh you're
from New Orleans though you can deal
with that
what's the difference have a heat though
you know I mean because we got that that
that stinky moistness and there's stick
in your ass you could probably cook
yourself yeah people are realize that
cargo is so [ __ ] cold in the winter
then you go out there in the summer
night this is brutal
in the summer Rae yes do you shooting
areas that there's a lot of bad [ __ ]
happening where they have
they have to kind of you know like get
permission or whatever to shoot in
certain areas absolutely absolutely I
mean but at the same time it's just I
mean it could be around the corner it
could be it could be anywhere in Chicago
you know what I mean in a I remember we
were shooting one of the scenes at at
the moms house at laverne's house right
and two blocks over there was like a
little a big commotion they pulled this
little Mexican guy at the house he might
have been five feet right all the guys
50s or 60s they found like 1.3 million
dollars in his house and it was like
what
dude she walks away from here doesn't
happen it was crazy like the police are
telling us all kind of crazy so they
just took a little investor out for
noise I got my own Bank
is there anybody around you that makes
you like worry about your successes
there's this scene at the end of the
season of the shy when your character
gets his food truck and everything seems
like it's finally on an upswing right
and then these gangsters came around
that you had had altercations with
earlier in the season when you realize
like [ __ ] he just can't get there this
is just right he can't bag right here
catch a break but it's interesting it's
interesting to think about because I got
the food truck and I got a load on the
food truck thinking I was gonna sell the
house right but now remember this is
want to sell the house so I mean I may
need a little help I may need a little
protection I may need a little extra
money so no you have to watch and see
how Brandon hits [ __ ] watch that show
you're like oh [ __ ] how does anybody
manage I don't understand what did you
want to do before you active oh you know
I don't know I'm just one of those guys
that I live for instant gratification
you know what I mean I found a lot of
happiness in like doing that's good work
cooking you know what I mean things like
that that you just that changed people's
lives or that make instant change and
though what's better doing electrical
work or working with dr. Dre on an NWA
movie
a matter of Jason was like I love
electrical I don't know if you want a
four-bedroom properly wired it more fun
to me yeah was it was that like really
intimidating just to be around those
guys knowing you're telling that story
and you're kind of like is that hot like
was there ever like looking to them like
was that how it was well you know he's
interesting because I like Dre right we
saw we seemed react yeah and he was like
yo I cannot tell you how like your
whole-- get down this was up to me
because I've acted in movies and I'm
terrible you're like you don't your gum
chewing and training day was strong very
like I don't know he calls it how he
sees it you know I mean it seems like
the higher you get up on the totem pole
then that's BS you hear you know what I
mean like Jimmy Iovine I've seen him
take literally 6 minutes in well 6
minutes with each person yeah in a
meeting but all of these people are
sitting on the couch together and he's
like well like like got like speed
dating yeah like six minutes you're done
now I'm going to talk to you Ouisa
billion and he's got busy because he's
got the answers like he can actually not
here's what we're gonna do and that's
what we're doing and go do that next all
right we're doing this with you next and
that's they don't have to wait for
approvals yeah right yeah when you make
the decision where I can just make the
decision it looks like you're doing
something but no you just don't have to
ask anybody for permission to do it
precisely this is the complete
elimination of bureaucracy
we're not like well let's see what they
say above it you're like I'm the guy up
here and that's cool you play easy
you're playing him in front of a guy who
knew him there's a lot of pressure with
that because this is not a fictional
character these are all people who are
his friends right absolutely that was
one of those things you mess it up just
don't come back yeah it was a thing that
not just dr. Dre had that feeling for it
but like the whole city you know what I
mean be like they would legit have
people just come watch you know and like
what are you gonna say yeah but it was
yeah cuz I guess nwe representing
Compton the same way
you're representing Chicago on the other
show exactly yeah
I remember one day specifically where we
did like the scene where we're getting
on the bus and off the bus and we also
did that uh the lowrider scene and all
that right it was all like in the same
spot in all the gangs came out that day
and they was like damn this is gonna get
bad you know but it was fall production
was like that yeah like they were really
nervous you can literally see clusters
of people in here the different colors
and you could it was all there
yeah but then they had his window I
don't forget here's like tattoos all
over his face and everything so he just
walked right past so funny to think of a
PA and a headset sir stop yes gangs it
doesn't matter everybody is interested
in that process like it Vietnam it was
crazy right because like we were here
one day in the Hill has like trees on
literally I'd say 75 people they're all
like like just crouch down cuz they do
like this little crouch down thing right
like when I just bended down but they're
all in the tree which was amazing
when she just looked up into some people
in tree John Goodman do a take you did a
lot of research on eazy-e right for the
role yeah did tell me your theory do you
think should got him no you don't do
that think that no how come
oh because there's steep this is deep I
don't I don't think she got him just for
the simple fact that aids is such a it's
a bigger thing it's a bigger thing it's
a it's a United States sort of thing and
after you are Eric litt right on a piece
of paper you've donated X amount of
dollars to the state of California and
then you go to the White House and they
realize the chillest same guy who made
[ __ ] the police
that's a mistake who is oh god the CC I
mean it was you know everything was on
paper yeah you know what I mean nobody's
nobody's Carly you uh err glib right you
know did he got it from sex uh I don't
know I mean I just I hate to call it
like I see it
yeah but it's it's an interesting
concept to think that he died so fast
from AIDS in out of seven baby when I
was nine kids nobody has it really I
didn't know that part that there's no
one oh I see what you're saying
you [ __ ] shake the system they shake
you checkers I don't know for they have
me so bro you know that's why I think
everybody's got their theories on it
just because out of nowhere nobody
around him was affected and it just
don't you all surprise back then weren't
getting tested for it all the time
probably you know it's one of those
things you're sick in a god I'm just
sick but you would think he would have
infected a ton of people maybe
absolutely I mean like just think about
it like like alright Widow like I think
you don't show it the movie would when
they found out he had AIDS
like like hundreds of people came to it
to the hospital like like crying like oh
my God my life is about to be over yeah
it was really legit trying to get
checked healer I'm saying like and to
think that like maybe him and some of
the guys from NWA didn't have sex with
the same women this
that's the last of course that the the
bunks everything that a groupie is right
because he's just trying to get on the
bus it's like I don't care whoever
exactly that may not be the sexy was
having though who knows yeah if you're
good if you're doing things that put you
at risk for that yeah you're at risk for
but the people you're having sex with
might not be as much at risk I don't
know I don't know I just I just think
it's interesting that nobody else was
there's right now nobody yeah yeah one
woman that's like he was me I was the
one that's [ __ ] crazy she said she
felt weird weird anything wrong was
there anything about like you see okay
watch him and you do watch interviews
and you interpret who he is and you try
to play him or be him was there anything
there like no no he didn't do this that
way that they didn't like how you
interpreted it well at the very
beginning like before I spoke to Tameka
which was his last wife you know a
business partner um I just assumed that
he smoked a lot of weed you don't assume
that he liked wooded dogs and drugs and
things like that she was like nah that
actually wasn't his thing you know what
I mean like sex was his holy drug and
money he was nearly addicted to money
you know what I mean he would give each
one of those little families 20 bands a
month that's a lot of money yeah yeah
like he was a serious threat like he was
making that kind of money did that
change the way you played the role when
you found that out were you're like oh
[ __ ] now you know now knowing just sex
and money is his thing
yeah absolutely just kind of gear
yourself towards that yeah I definitely
did it definitely did because like the
amazing one shot that we have the famous
hotel see yeah it was originally created
to not only do this beautiful one shot
and see how we operated in hotels and
things like that but also like to
justify me get my hair braided and I was
like why you're gonna be like this guy's
having sex in the bed like himmat Yeller
used to have these these these things
where like they would see who could
sleep with the most women in each city
and it was so petty to where like one
day they were both had ten women right
and they're like these were shaking in
any particular City for a day or two
right right right they're pulling it off
right you know like they have a girl
and they were he looks over he was like
I would have been the worst friend of
theirs I'd be like I had six months of
good all day just talk to the girls
after they [ __ ] guys okay I'd like to
keep it at 68 for one load every nine
hours turtle load right so it's kind of
amazing you go from I mean in terms of
the big big rolls you go from the
Straight Outta Compton movie right which
completely I think put you on the map
right but that's a high-pressure role
yeah then you go to the scheie which I
think as a dramatic actor did a lot for
you that's a lot of pressure because
it's Chicago right now you got to remake
Superfly right yes it's like you know
there are people who live and die by
that movie absolutely absolutely and I
think um I think we did a great job you
know I mean I really do think we did a
great job it was a movie that uh I feel
like it needed that extra little step
you know I really needed the fast motion
he needed the everything that an action
film has it needed that you know what I
mean because like the movies that I grew
up on like Beverly Hills Cop and it you
know I mean these are all movies that
are like funny and fascinating but the
bullets are still real what I mean yes
you know you learn something from so
it's just yeah
is there any Curtis Mayfield in the
movie at all we had of course I was like
gonna be this morning like we couldn't
get the licensing we have on the sheet
superfreak is in theaters or up the prep
sheet wrong
confuse I'm like he says one movie
shooting and one movie that's done
Superfly it's in theaters Wednesday June
13th
yeah do you get nervous for that
something comes at you you pay attention
to numbers or or how people are
responding to it are you one of those
guys that doesn't give a [ __ ] I don't
care at all I don't care because the
thing is of the day I let it all hang
out ya know so I've never like leave the
field feeling like I yeah I just don't
you know so I just I let it go and I'm
not one of those guys who like to watch
playback or anything it's kind of sweet
about watching myself it's the worst
it's the worst watching yourself is you
see myself real you bring up the second
take I like my way better on the second
take when you when you had that thing on
that Delta flight which we all have
things right is it like now that you're
you know you're a lot more famous than
you worry like i'll [ __ ] everyone's got
a camera i in public you just that's
what I was writing is that when you
realize like oh [ __ ] I'm I'm really
famous yeah that was one of those blows
they are you slowly see the phone's pop
it up would you like come already here
we go you know what the happiest day of
my life you know what I kind of liked it
like even as you knew the cameras were
all out yeah you stayed the same
like your that's that guy you didn't get
violent you didn't get like it's like
okay I kind of I get who that guy is and
he's not that different
he's just mad right now dude but man it
happened Chad Coleman who I love who was
in the wires in the walking dead had
that meltdown on the train in New York
yeah that meltdown over it oh my god was
in a subway car was drunk do you
remember that travels like I'm sure I'm
walking dead it was one of those things
I just try not to be like but I just
worked with Delta in no they did they
gave me like five thousand dollars to do
one of those things like hi I'm Jason
Mitchell I took my first Delta flight
now that's what I was I was so happy for
you that you didn't do that because I
who did that like Reese Witherspoon you
know who I am yes people will be--that
so late but I just like ma'am just
please take a look at what ticket it was
$7,800 yeah like we can oh please you
seem genuinely hurt by the whole thing
okay just why is this happening right I
really was come on cuz we they they did
the stinger there's a can everybody
evacuate that the plane knows I come on
that's that's nice now get off your
argument yeah I'll get off but still
like it's $7,800 you're gonna hear my
mouth how long do you have to wait for
your next flight
the next day did you make what you
needed to make or no the show the shy
did cost not huh if [ __ ] 914
thousand 36 cents a minute
to shoot at the TV show so who was to be
the young black guy just went to Vegas
is back late you don't know me no use
trying it's a [ __ ] personal time and
then go back to work because we're
before 16-hour days well actually
Showtime surprised me with the tickets
they was like you've been doing so good
you know we know that because they heard
that fluid bed whether it was like my
dream role yeah I mean it was like we
heard you wanted to go to floor fight so
we got your two tickets it was like what
what was it what you gotta do is get
yourself there back we got you a room
with everything else that's amazing yeah
so I got like a last buddy ticket but
and then you notice that you get that
same are you wait for it but you get
that guilt because something so nice was
given to you because you're doing well
at your job and you gotta get back to
the job and then Delta's [ __ ] with
you and you're like I just gotta get
back to work
yeah I understand I think feeling like
almost like a guilt towards like what
the [ __ ] I got given this nice thing and
now I got to get back as fast as I can
we just discovered why Jason Mitchell
cleans up all the chairs on the set you
know there's gonna be a Loman chanko
fight coming up for chairs
so that's your dream role Floyd
Mayweather yeah so would you do the like
extreme actor thing and get into like
ridiculous Floyd Mayweather shape and
yell because um when I first met him it
was it was very brief yeah I mean he was
like I'm a big fan and everything
everything right and we're all like
shudders because I went to uh I wanted
to say was agenda or magic the UM the
the thing that they have in Vegas like
the what he called it the the fashion
so I met him there and then we went out
afterwards and it was almost 11 o'clock
and he was like all right yeah I'll
rather than our Father you know me there
you know some people was like meantime
this [ __ ] whatever whatever and he was
like oh fluid about the ghosts are his
workout that's crazy I was like what he
was like yeah you know the body is
designed to go to sleep at night but we
fight at night so if I do my workout at
night you know why I started at night
then by the time a person's body's
shutting down that's when I'm I'm happy
myself I'm like you know so he goes to
he works out at 11:00 p.m.
yeah he starts his run at 11:00 then
again when you're Floyd Mayweather and
you could do whatever you want whenever
you want doesn't matter if you finish it
4:00 in the morning you go out and do
whatever the [ __ ] you want Debu like us
if we're like I'm gonna do a set at 4:00
p.m. and I'm here to do a comedy yeah is
there anything else that what are you
looking forward to doing coming up the
head they have so much I want to try but
I love playing villains right
and I feel like um every villain has
like a really good soft spot you know I
mean but like Vincent D'Onofrio is one
of my favorite guys Helen I don't know
if y'all watch daredevil yeah but I
thought it was really interesting like
how they introduced his character as
this very nervous timid like I want to
impress this girl to her graduation with
the art yeah then he like slams this
guy's head in the door so he literally
said was it you know at me because he
messed the data and and the whole
background of the he loves that painting
because reminds me of the wall that he
looked at every [ __ ]
Danah when you're like yeah that's great
right you gonna mean so I just think
it's interesting um like how you know
different you can be naive Michael
Shannon a nice man
you don't mean yeah man I was so mad
about me to go now you can't let it go
now I have to kill you you that was one
of my favorite books and I love Michael
Shannon I was so excited for him to play
a richard kuklinski and then it came out
like a [ __ ] action movie yeah where
it was like this dude was a psycho that
just murdered people they made him like
he just needed that voice was radioed in
that he played Roy DeMeo that's right
yeah when it has the best laugh in the
words yeah Akeelah remembered who's
doing those tequila commercials laughing
do you is it tougher to make choices now
that like when stuff is successful right
and you start to build this name for
yourself yeah does it become more
difficult for you to make your choices
in terms of I have to keep this momentum
going oh not really not really I think
it comes in like me just not what the
sort of same thing you know over and
over because I think so many people get
caught up in like like first it so easy
right they called me for the michel a
movie they called me for everything that
easy you could possibly be in you know
they need like people like let's make a
part two with flashbacks of easy I'm
like guys what do we do easy as a
guardian angel be comfortable I've been
asked to do like oh like holographic
performances it's a bunch of stuff [ __ ]
guys I don't want to say no just stop
it's hard to say no for the money no not
really not really because I feel like
I've done the family such a great
justice you go to God like it's just
downhill from there when the guy who
played biggie and notorious pops up as
biggie Tupac biggie again on that USA or
the judge is different wait wait he
played biggie three times oh did he
really
yeah he just gets the call and he's like
he has put his biggie boys on it Oh
until I can't do what he's like I got
change Oh hold good we gotta get those
cold good
[Laughter]